ein klick sei verriet erst würde ich
gern sagen verriet deine musik ist
wirklich der hammer und du kannst dich
drauf verlassen dass ich weiter
unterstützen werde
zu meiner frage du hast selber gesagt
das jahr 2011 für das er 2000 und ich
würde gerne wissen was hast du 2011
alles vor und vor allem von welchem
deutschen rapper willst du gerne
karriere beenden weil ich weiß dass oder
bestimmten wir erstmal geiler typ man
sieht auf jeden fall die leute die mich
zur porten die das sind auf jeden fall
gut aussehende leute erstmal jentsch in
busan disch dank für den support und die
karre 2011 wird auf jeden fall 2000
besteht in großarl natur steht bevor im
mai ansonsten bin ich gerne die karriere
zerstören würde das natürlich nur um
garten und stück arbeit dazu aber ich
denke mal das wird sich über die jahre
werde ich das auch gut hinkriegen dass
der junge herr sido